allure les gilet jaune se sont organisés
pour durer un abri qui leur sert de
cantine sur un terrain privé pour ne pas
se faire déloger un point d'appui pour
les autres gillet qui depuis le début
sont présents sur ce rond-point juste à
côté
alors demain samedi on attend beaucoup
de monde et on est même prêt à pousser
les murs donc on a monté ça hier et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on va faire une
extension pour pouvoir recevoir un peut
pas se mettre à l'abri des gens quand
ils pleurent parce que c'est pas évident
et puis qu'est voilà ça veut dire ce
qu'on me disait tout à l'heure ses
cloches c'est parti pour durer
les manifestations à paris ici on les
regarde de très loin personne ne prendra
le chemin de la capitale demain allure
c'est sur ce rond point que les autres
gilets sont attendus françois lui est là
depuis le début
il a même dormi sur place j'ai dormi 19
bon jeu malgré la grève ça va continuer
même demain demain après demain après
nouvelle hanche il faut pratiquement un
mois après le début du mouvement
ici tout le monde reste mobilisé
personne lâche tout le monde doit être
là sur place il y aura de plus en plus
de monde devant le faux qui est quand
même du monde donc ça c'est un impératif
que les gens sur l'urée environ doivent
se sentir concernés
l'acte ii allure c'est sûrement cette
réorganisation du mouvement pour
l'installer dans la durée avant ce
nouveau samedi de mobilisation nationale